if there was ever a week for a Dan
bungee no Friday news explosion it's
this week a favorite new york city cop
here to break down everything huge that
happened he also by the way is a brand
new book exonerated the failed takedown
in president donald trump by the swamp
outstanding damn Panchito joins us
Congrats on the book down by the way
oh yeah thanks tucker we lay out the
blueprint you know they tried this scam
before this rush inclusion thing so i
deeply appreciate you mention in a book
but let's get to the news explosion
because my favorite segment of the week
we have two stories this week but really
three because there's a tie for number
one and stay tuned we'll be giving out a
special award at the end so whose story
number two hillary clinton corruption
fighter tucker warrior against
corruption hillary get your bearings
here listen I have done props see if we
here's the penalty flag um Hillary
Clinton illegal procedure 15 yards
corruption fighter now what's the
genesis of this she claims Donald Trump
and I quote I had to write this down
Hillary Clinton who's back on the scene
again is a corrupt human tornado so
Tucker I don't like writing notes for
the segment but when it comes to Hillary
Clinton's corruption you need some notes
I had uranium one pay-to-play and the
Clinton Foundation her Ukraine Pinchak
scandals The Rose law firm Spygate
Hillary just a note you may just want to
sit this one out I'm just saying
protip on I think that's probably a
pretty good vice corruption fighter who
knew right
okay story number one now we have a
little competition with
we got a special award today and the
winner for the best dramatic retelling
of a Democrat fake news hoax we have two
contestants we have Adam Schiff who
reinvented the entire transcript and the
congressional hearing yesterday and the
Ukraine call and told the totally
different story hyperbolic story of what
Trump said to the Ukrainian president he
was very gifted though Tucker in his
retelling I want to compliment him on
his skills there and then the New York
Times decided they were gonna get
creative their opinion section and they
put out a tweet with the Star Wars
scroll telling what they believe to be
the Trump story of corruption of course
their fake news story so Tucker I have
the envelope we have a winner here who
wins attention building the winner is
Adam Schiff actually this is an invite
to my seven-year-old daughter's dinner
party the win Tucker we have a trophy
here it is this is actually my
daughter's lacrosse trophy from the
stick let's lacrosse but you get an Adam
Schiff come claim your trophy it's here
in Palm City Florida you know you don't
want him there
damn bad you know great to see you have
a best weekend